WOLTERSTORFF: Ken is up there. So what I heard
Roherty saying--
I knew Roherty, so--
we were friends.
He-- what he wanted to do was enforce
a Deweyan--
a pretty thick
John Deweyan view of democracy on people, and
that just felt
oppressive to me.
But you raise the really important question,
of course, of--
can we can eliminate all--
everything of that sort?
Won't there be a moral gap-- which in a way goes
back to the fear of all these people,
I mean--
"What do you mean,
a state which is not,
unified by some--
which does not have some sort of religious
moral unity in the people?"
Now. So, liberal democracy is clearly not--
it's clearly not a neutral
arrangement. I mean, it's obviously got
commitments. I think it's got deep commitments
to human rights, and if people--
if somebody thinks that there are no human
rights, then they've got real trouble with the
liberal democracy.
So-- so I said-- the accusations that
it's amoral-- I don't believe that. In fact
it is
a moral structure of its own sort, very different
from previous ones, but it's not
an amoral structure. But I think
on lots of issues that we debate,
we live with the reality that
we don't have
a shared--
I mean, so, it's shared structural principles--
but we live with the reality that we don't
have shared principles which are going to
yield consensus.
The present health care
debate-- it is messy because it is filled with
so many economic complications and so forth.
I think the cleanest illustration of this
point was the
debate over
physician-assisted suicide, which took place
in the state of Oregon about fifteen years ago.
Economics was not--
well, I mean a few people raised an economic
issue-- "it's just too expensive to take care of
all the people"-- but by and large, that...
And what you found was,
a wholeÉ [Inaudible joke from Blair]
And what you found was a whole array of
fascinatingly articulate but different
moral positions coming out. Not one, but--
not one secular and not one religious one.
There was no religious person who was
so heavy-handed as to say, "God told me last
night that
physician-assisted suicide is wrong, so it is,
and that's the end of the matter." Nobody
was so flat-footed as that. You had utilitarians,
and you had these economizers who said, "It's
just too expensive to take care of old people and
so forth."
What we have-- what we do at the end of the
day:
just take a vote.
We haven't achieved consensus.
We take a vote. And that's a mighty risky procedure.
You know of a better one?
STUDENT: No, I think that's
right. My question--
WOLTERSTORFF: What's the option?
So, I'm just going to force you to--
STUDENT: My only concern is that--
how do we ensure that
people respect there being a vote, for instance? Is that
something we just assume,
that people will always have--"Oh, let's go to a vote."
That seems to me something that
does require a particular cultivation of thought-- and I'm concerned
that you saying that we shouldn't traffic in the business
of comprehensive doctrines
runs the risk of us getting to the point where the vote
is not what we in fact go back to.
WOLTERSTORFF: So, I think we have to pay a lot of attention
to the character of the preliminary debate.
Things that Tony said, things that I said.
A lot of attention to that.
Then-- and one of things-- one of the things--
one of the reasons that each of us
should listen to the
voice of the other,
is so that when we decide to vote against
them,
finally--
against their position--
we know what we're voting against. We're voting
against Joel, who
has expressed with great eloquence his own-- whatever.
Muslim, Jewish, Buddhist
position, whatever.
And now I find that I still disagree with him,
and I have to vote against him.
I think that's one of the reasons why it's
important to allow these voices to come forth--
so we know--
so I--
if I'm voting against Joel, I know
who it is--
what position it is that I'm actually voting against.
But then we have to take--
take the vote, and try to make that vote
as fair as possible.
So here-- so here's what's--
here's what's eating--
here's what's guiding people like Audi and Rawls
and so forth:
a noble vision
of a society in which all of us are co-authors
of the legislation.
We are co-authors.
Nobody's handing it down; we are co-authors.
That's the basic idea.
And if you're a co-author, you're not coerced, right?
Of course.
I think that's a noble idea.
It just doesn't work.
VOLF: É if you need to nurture
procedures, within those democratic procedures, there are values
and virtues that--
WOLTERSTORFF: Absolutely.
VOLF: So there are substantive
virtues embedded in the very democratic--
WOLTERSTORFF: Exactly. We've gotta
talk about the virtues of the process
and the debate. Absolutely.
My lament is that we're
violating those virtues
flamboyantly in the US today.
BLAIR: I mean, I--
I think it's--
so I was thinking about
debates, and of the vote and so on, and then
the various
views that we put for, and there was a--
When you lead a political party, basically,
you are the recipient of a lot of advice,
and-- of varying degrees of sense--
and...
the first leader of the British Labour Party
was a Scotch guy named Keir Hardie--
who was a very tough-minded guy, but he was
trying to get the
party off the ground-- win support in an
election for women's suffrage.
And
the Pankhursts, who were campaigning for
women's suffrage, they'd also--
another part of their work was
they studied the
incidence of various
sexual diseases and they'd
come to the conclusion that this was all because
of the proclivities of men.
And they wrote-- the sisters wrote to
Keir Hardie, who was the leader, and said--
before the election-- they said, "We would like to put forth
the following proposition to you:
that you campaign
on a--
a slogan
of "Votes for women, and abstinence for men."
To which Keir Hardie replied-- he said, "Thank you very
much for your advice,
the election-winning propensities of which
are not discernible."
So-- don't know why I mentioned that-- but anyway...
I think--
you see, I think that the-- I think
that
Nick made a very important
point about the--
the preliminary debate
at least has got to be
drawn in a very
careful way. You see--
I mean I've faced-- I mean Nathan was asking me for
practical examples-- I mean, just to give a couple:
we had a-- I started a
program of schools in the UK
slightly similar to your charter schools--
but they were called
the academy system,
which has now, you know, developed into a major part
of our secondary school systemÉ But
there were--
there was a major philanthropist
who wanted to start
such schools up in the-- up in the northeast,
who was a creationist.
And the question arose whether as a
creationist it was right that he could
start these schools because of the
influence on-- on
the children, and in the end, you know,
sometimes
at the cusp of these things, you have to decide
it in quite a difficult way,
so we decided in the end--
I decided--
he should be able
to start those schools
but he could not
teach creationism as the--
you know, he could not contradict the
curriculum.
Now,
you need, I think,
to have certain--
to get this attitude of mind,
I don't think you can leave it to chance--
I mean, this what Kenneth was saying--
I
believe, for example, that
because of the importance-- the reason for
this course and the
reason why I think
education policy has got to take account of
the fact that religious and faith literacy
today is an important part of understanding the
society
and world in which you grow up, and therefore I think
that needs to amend,
you know,
the policy that we have.
Now does that mean that everybody
will agree?
No. And does that mean occasionally, as
with Switzerland, that you end up in a
situation where people
collectively take an action that is contrary
to the basic--
to, really, what
the country is about, actually.
No, it doesn't mean that. You will get that.
But that makes it all the more important
for that open attitude.
to be, I think,
quite a deliberative
proposition advanced
on behalf of the--
WOLSTERSTORFF: Does Switzerland have a constitution?
BLAIR: It does have a constitution, but the constitution
tends to focus more on
the sort of
technical, you know--
the division between the powers of the central
government and the cantons and so on. And although
it does have--
it does have
human rights legislation.
Now I think one thing that is interesting
is this, and this-- both Allen's point and Rich's
points
do this, I think:
that there will inevitably be situations in which
there's a conflict. Right?
And what's more, and I think this is a very important
point about the way things evolve--
I mean, I used to study
the American constitutional cases--
you know Brown and Board of Education and so on and
so forth and--
the fact is what happened
was that the courts, in a sense, reflected,
as their decisions changed, the evolution of
society.
And so certain attitudes
held at one time became, over time, unacceptable
attitudes. Now, but here's what I think is important
though:
the fact that you had a proper due
process,
and the fact that you have a
framework within which these
arguments
take place-- I think this is of itself helpful.
And that it takes place
by reference to an argument
that is an argument that in some sense
is, I think,
morally, not merely contractually, inspired.
Now I think, you know-- so
when I was
kind of your age as a student, I used to say,
"Look, really, all that's happened is society's
changed."
But now I take a slightly more sophisticated
view of that process, and think,
"Yes, it's true, but actually the very fact
that there was a process within which these--
these issues were aired and determined
that had reference to this constitutional framework
of rights was actually very important in resolving
this
in the correct way." And you might have waited,
incidentally, a lot longer
for some of these decisions to come, right?
Were it not for that fact. Now,
it is, however,
a situation
in which it does call for
open attitudes
from the non-religious
and the religious.
And where you get on--
where you get, for example, a closed attitude
on behalf of the religious,
you will get the reaction
from the non-religious.
And that's why this debate--
it's quite important that it's-- it sees by
what I would say is the sort of sensible and intelligent
conceptual middle ground, to--
to push
the extremes back, because--
let's be very clear about this.
The reaction in parts of Europe
that is taken on in certain
occasions, an anti-
Islamic
character
is as a result of the feeling
that there are those within
the religious faith of islam who are pushing.
what people think is an inconsistent view
about basic politics on the rest of the population.
So that's why you need--
this is why I say, I think this debate--
'cause I really do believe, in a sense, that
for the majority of people, I mean, what Nick
has outlined is--
you know, I think as a
I mean, would kind of win the election,
as it were-- I mean,
you know, in other words-- most people would say,
"Well, it seems to me sensible enough,"
because it's--
it's a pretty open attitude. But it has to
be
something, then-- I think it's the policy
conclusion from that that interests me,
this-- how you then
can inculcate and encourage that,
how civic society, not just government,
takes a role in that-- how academic institutions,
also, develop
the research that shows that
the open societies
can also lead to--
to greater
endeavour and prosperity.
You know, I was saying to the
colleagues who were here from Peking University
today that one really interesting thing
to me is,
in China, how
the modern leadership
is referencing its
open
policy today,
not to the changes
of the sixty years since the
the revolution in China, but actually
way back in time
to, say, when
Confucianism was developing, and
China was at that point a very
open trading nation-- that was when it was successful.
It then closed down, became unsuccessful.
And now it's opening up again it--
you know, and-- I think
these things have to be fought for; that's my
point.
So when you look at the Netherlands--
I mean, most--
most people are--
are obviously shocked at what happened.
But the only way of
retrieving the situation
is to try and give some sense of
a common
space and
a common set of shared
purposes and values. So,
for example, after the London bombing
in July
2005,
my first statement-- I mean, I knew you would get
at a later stage
to other things, but my first statement
was a statement about
shared values,
about the fact that
any anti-Muslim sentiment coming out of this
would be wrong and aggressive,
and would undermine the basis of our society.
So that was my
first-- almost like a kind of philosophical
political statement to bring people together.
But I was also aware, and when I got to this
a few months later, people kind of thought one
was inconsistent with the other--
where I said, "Right, now we're also going to use
the following rules,
right? We are not going to have
imams coming in from abroad
who are not certified by some process
as having a
certain amount of religious
achievement, and also a
particular attitude."
We can't afford to have someone coming into
our society
saying, "You are the enemy if you are not
of my religion."
So, and then people said, "Well that's--
you know, there's this very nice
broad philosophical statement, and now you're
taking some quite tough measures here."
But I said, you know, the one is necessary
in order to protect the other.
And actually what happens
is-- and I have this debate often with
people on the
progressive side of politics is that--
such open attitudes
and the protection of your basic
common space-- it doesn't happen by accident,
right? And it--
there are plenty of people who will--
it might happen naturally, but there are also people
prepared to interfere with that process.
And so you do have to--
you know, the policy implications of this, I think,
are quite,
quite profound,
and make
a lot of difference in the way that
politics then interacts with the world of
religion.
VOLF: É this point with the Swiss case with the ban,
if I'm informed correctly, it is the complacency
of the opponents of the ban
that allowed the ban to go through. They simply
took it for granted that Swiss will not
pass the vote, right? So it's
a lock of democratic functioning-- in a sense,
democratic engagement that
allowed it to happen.
VOLTERSTORFF: And I think what happened in Dutch--
my ancestry is Dutch, so I
care about it and so forth--
so I think about what happened in the Dutch
case, and it's still happening,
is that Holland had been-- had become
a very homogeneous society; it
for centuries had had a Jewish component, but it--
it worked out for accommodations and
Jews held honored positions in the society and so forth--
and now suddenly--
and the Dutch are feeling good about themselves and all that--
now suddenly there's this group
who in all kinds of ways is simply not
part of the Dutch consensus. They've got no interest
in participating in the Dutch government. They do get
"doles" from the Dutch government, and this is
resented-- welfare from the Dutch
government, and this is resented and so forth.
So--
I think American society and probably British
society would have been--
would be far
better able to handle
this new group than the Dutch were. They
had no experience with--
or such experience that they had was
centuries in the past.
This was outside
the implicit consensus they'd had--
BLAIR: I'd emend that by saying, I actually think America would have
handled this better then
either of our--
WOLTERSTORFF: Ok.
BLAIR: I think
European society--
I think your very
constitution, with the points that you're making, is one of the major
reasons why.
WOLTERSTORFF: And we're much bigger-- I mean,
fifteen million homogenous people--
suddenly you--
as opposed to how many do--
three hundred million, whatever?
Not homogenous.